[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you okay presentation to council
[Music]
[Music]
ministers and they don't even State
[Music]
Council's my name is Derek an increase
in the safety of 5g national
environmental standards Lord has taken
away accountable councils ability to
Christian the deployment of
telecommunication structures this law is
also taken away democratic rights to
lobby on council regarding this issue
we have a council still there's a duty
to protect the health lives of those
they represent we reach to the safety of
five Gd and based on pupils scientific
evidence and infringement of our
democratic and human rights we would
like to work with Council to find a way
to raise heavens man
the robber peyote has provoked several
lawsuits overseas my suit is challenging
the resource management and national
environmental standards for
telecommunications facilities regulation
2016 in relation to 4.55 corolla i have
supplies you with this continent five
deep transmitters are covered by the New
Zealand radio frequency field exposure
standard and the New Zealand exposure
standard limits are based on guidelines
set by the International Commission on
non ionizing radiation protection I will
refer to this from now on
as ignorant ignorant as a private and
non-governmental organization based in
Germany you members can only elected by
members of the organization many on the
ignorant members kept ice industry in
the Diwan theater guidelines this
creates a serious conflict of interest a
statement guidelines are huge economic
strategic importance to these industries
but a 20-year old New Zealand standard
is indiscriminate about danger complete
scientific knowledge in before New
Zealand government adopted the guideline
in 1999 whistleblower dr. Neely Warren
strongly against it calling him fatally
flawed the length of material was a
senior lecturer at Lincoln University
physicist trained an electricity and
magnetism radiation physics in the face
of mind works in his favor criticism on
health assessment and the Dignam
guidelines
radiofrequency microwave radiation 100
kilograms to 300 gigahertz alliance
failed to protect public health from
potential financial health is in
contrast to the International Agency for
research on
escuela radiofrequency radiation is
possible passenger group to be in 2011
new research supports every
characterization to group one an outcast
in general the most recent findings have
been dismissed by economists by paving
less costly and official given the 2018
conclusions of the National Toxicology
program by the US Department not how
this line to sit down at any study of
rogues and rodents Acosta 30 million
Jewish scholars before concluding with
clear evidence a link between mobile
phone radiation and cancer this is also
the bank by the ramesseum Institute
initially reported parallel findings in
a related project the internet exposure
guidelines was used by many agencies
worldwide including including mobile you
see the government only provides
protection against some short-term
eating effects of radiofrequency
radiation it does not protect against
the long-term continuous non-eating
effects that we've already supposed to
but the implementation on 5g
as small cells required for nearest
stream into our schools homes and
workplaces the standard does not protect
against fatigue insomnia DNA damage
infertility
cancer another affects the proliferation
of wireless technology with 3G 4G Wi-Fi
Bluetooth smart meters and the emergence
of 5t plus the Internet of Things and
will massively increase the public's
exposure to radiofrequency radiation
however these guidelines still be valid
as these technologies that don't exist
at the time when they were implemented
and using the standard reason being if I
ain't no government as thousands of here
in these days indicating they're ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've been working and communicating with
to to further you know Venus not their
government I understand why you want
change then there will be we need to be
written
[Music]
[Music]
the source mentioned eight wouldn't need
to be altered because that's what allows
cows to be built at the diamond would
need to be opened because their act
allows these tears to be built at the
moment so yes so existing sites we have
do they change it over like they put
explain me like there's a 5g thing going
to an existing site where they creating
new towers and new sites that was
hearing to patient in these elements
what
the cells to the one-state need to be
specific 100 200 years apparent that
will be the main history there's
bringing you know radiation and closer
to people's homes schools and workplaces
so you know very much the proliferation
of Moscow hotels every year for this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the item is open for discussion
in question you think your worship hmm
so darling you've done a million $3
million three thousand plus I'm just
wondering that I see a gates 22 it would
be really good to write down
[Music]
[Music]
I guess is fun they're pretty key cuz
it's only really be true victory or
anyway I still were actually behind
where we thought would be at this point
an alt because some approaches have been
delayed through particular project and
the civic administration we were lost
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we have progress
[Music]
[Music]
a comment question I think it's just a
small taste of the extent and the stroke
so they were facing counseling when you
say in reality just a question on the
island maybe talking here you've told me
about using reserves
thank you worship and
mate I was just wondering a staff taking
states to know what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how does this report in doing due
diligence on this it's not a full-time
neck and they asked as a council and
they write down know they own the
difference in we can get on with having
uh I see a job that at least all the
right guys know exactly where they found
his line and it's definitely from the
boundary to the road stiffly is and I
think it's about time that we did did
this change you just figure I think the
updated policy it's a taste
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
things I see them my introductory
remarks seems to be it is really dry on
any plane and we are talking about least
wanting this really it's one area where
you plan to be aspirational and might be
there this time around maybe
- their assets funding systems that may
[Music]
safely thing I see still take long words
and bring all the components coherent
pieces work and it's normally taken by a
series of little shops
tops team two years process what is
still playing I think certainly the
first four years where that's fresh
consultation and get a mirror currently
fine-tuning and finalizing they feed
into
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
sitting things before
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I certainly support this recommendation
and I do it up until recently
another key coin will be made around the
decision is that registered charity it's
not just health facility no more the
communities which is a charity in where
they all sport and just a complete lack
of community family recommendation there
is reason to be seen thing that we
haven't done so much in the past with
them descending building this was turned
into feeding on the past and Prada green
Buick even where we do do this they're
putting in another grand just for me we
didn't feel on the rural populations
even as we would help of council she's
no fun this year so it's within your
hands very carefully if you want to
change the river fires and policy in
place if we have additional grass
because we could teach the art of
thinking basis
where somebody is his moral very little
better writers if I make a contribution
so community a stuff like that and don't
get it before usual for you I am
absolutely thrilled thank yours is
armored with horse yet on this one not
so long ago we granted someone $10,000
for it I'm building to help them out so
I much rather give them to the core
health and knowing it canceled over the
year hopefully I know never user balance
their for any other right past it might
need it it's just for the knowledge
discretionary grants so when we're
talking about we do we actually obtain
funding from something we'll be
discussing we've proved this this ground
there will be something we'll be
discussing of course what we're heating
towards they mail they write discussions
obviously with a commentary also to
completely support the fact that the
ground would be appropriate for this
just follow on I think it would be
useful there were a CEO a take an
inkless was the council just to bring
the council up to speed with reality of
all the hospitals in the organization's
that's operating me because we
understand as we do found that it's
already in the hospital singing yeah
because there is a bigger picture in
terms of Hell gory times as hospital
anymore it's not just about
[Music]
I think this is a good because the cows
are banging into smashing
what are you voting against we don't
know we don't approve the ground to
Malthus it is a your vote I've just been
looking at a pair will be able to
proportion you can actually change the
policy and era girl from eight coming up
this has been deferred as it is iners so
they can come later we need to think
apparently fun date
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to start one creature that probably
related but in relation to came up
regarding
rebates we look at the how much we
actually qualifies for brain really
Nerium how many people get it and what
the total is okay and it's just just so
the total value because they can sorry
do you wish
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everything fades it's not beating each
other up